[Musique]
bonjour à tous est-ce que vous allez
bien
merci je m'appelle Vanessa et j'ai 23
ans donc pendant ce petit moment qu'on
va partager et bien je vais vous
partager un bout de mon histoire de mon
parcours mais aussi de ma vision de la
vie à travers un mode de pensée
pour commencer j'aimerais vous poser une
question enfin j'en ai déjà posé une
deuxième question
pouvez-vous me dire le nombre de d'idées
de pensées que vous avez eu depuis votre
réveil ce matin
c'est dur cette question était là pour
vous montrer qu'on était incapable de
mesurer le nombre d'idées qui ne
traversent l'esprit parce qu'on y
constamment en train de réfléchir qu'on
soit dans la douche en train de conduire
ou bien vous même en ce moment et parmi
ces pensées certaines sont négatives les
je ne suis pas capable je n'y arriverai
pas ou bien simplement je vais passer
une mauvaise journée vous voyez de quoi
je parle et bien sachez que qu'en
pensant de cette manière c'est-à-dire
négativement on se conditionne alors
aussi anodine que j'ai pensé plus être
en pensant de cette manière on limite
nos performances en se disant qu'on est
nul on perd en capacité parce qu'on
matérialise ce que l'on pense
pour certaines personnes ce genre de
pensée disparaît aussi vite qu'elle
arrive mais pour d'autres à partir du
moment où elles vont prendre conscience
de ses pensées elles vont commencer à
grandir à grandir à tel point qu'elles
vont impacter les émotions et les
comportements
vous avez déjà remarqué que quand vous
êtes en colère stressé ou bien triste
vous êtes beaucoup plus fatigué que
d'habitude
si les conséquences de ces pensées
négatives sur votre organisme qui draine
votre énergie sans même que vous en
rendiez compte
et ces conséquences peuvent même aller
au-delà de la fatigue et provoquer des
pathologies graves comme comme des
maladies auto-immunes
comment c'est possible et bien quand
vous êtes malade votre corps fabrique
des anticorps pour lutter contre cette
maladie le danger et bien quand vous
êtes concentré trop longtemps à des
sources de stress votre corps réagit de
la même manière votre cerveau détecte un
danger et on voit donc des signaux
d'alerte à votre corps qui réagit sauf
que sur une période beaucoup trop longue
et bien c'est défenses immunitaires
deviennent beaucoup deviennent des
nocives pour nous pardon et je sais de
quoi je parle je l'ai vécu
on va maintenant faire un bon de trois
ans en arrière j'ai 20 ans je suis une
jeune étudiante fraîchement diplômée
d'un bac + 2 et j'étais une jeune
étudiante pleine de vie et qui allait
faire son entrée dans la vie active pour
un bac + 3 avec sa première alternance
tout se passait bien les premiers mois
même si j'avais pas énormément de de
d'idées sur le monde professionnel mais
j'étais motivé à apprendre
mais au fur et à mesure du temps je me
rends compte que j'ai voulu dans un
environnement de travail nocif ou le
stress la pression et surtout la
méchancetéenne alors tout ça comment
savoir un impact sur moi d'abord sur mon
mental parce que je me demande j'ai
constamment des pensées négatives à me
demander comment va se passer cette
journée et si je fais une erreur et si
je suis pas assez productive qu'est-ce
qui va
et donc tout ça à force d'être mal
mentalement tout ça des répercussions
sur mon physique sur ma santé j'ai
constamment cette boule au ventre vous
connaissez cette boule de stress je
n'arrive même plus à manger je n'arrive
même plus à dormir et pour couronner le
tout je vais plus de 30 fois par jour
aux toilettes je vous laisse imaginer
mon état
alors pendant plusieurs mois j'enchaîne
les arrêts maladie les causes arrêt
maladie mais à un moment donné à force
de trop tirer sur la corde elle finit
par lâcher
je me souviens encore de ce moment
c'était un lundi au mois d'avril 2021
j'étais en cours à Saint-Pierre et lors
de la pause méridienne à midi alors que
je voulais retourner à ma voiture je
m'écroule
je m'écoule de douleur tellement c'était
devenu insupportable alors à ce moment
là j'ai pu d'autre choix que de me
rendre aux urgences
j'ai cru que bêtement que ce premier
séjour à l'hôpital allait me guérir et
que j'aurais pu revivre une vie normale
mais j'étais loin du compte
quelques semaines plus tard le
diagnostic tombe
j'ai développé une maladie chronique de
l'intestin
à 20 ans
on m'annonce que je suis maintenant
atteinte d'un handicap invisible et que
ma vie allait changer
de vous à moi ma première réaction a été
de nier totalement déjà par peur mais
aussi par honte de mon état
mais la réalité m'a vite rattrapé
moi qui était indépendante j'ai dû
retourner chez mes parents parce que
j'étais incapable de m'occuper de moi ou
de mon foyer je me suis mis en arrêt
maladie prolongée parce que je ne
voulais plus retourner dans cet
environnement de travail
j'ai quand même essayé de continuer à
suivre les cours parce que je voulais
avoir mon diplôme à la fin de l'année
mais je ne pouvais plus sortir je ne
pouvais plus sortir plus d'une heure
sans risquer une crise
alors tout ça m'a conduit à me renfermer
ça va briser j'étais devenue quelqu'un
de très faible physiquement qui tenait à
peine sur ses jambes et aussi
mentalement
cette période de crise a duré près de
deux ans et pendant ces deux ans j'ai
touché le fond
mais vous savez le point positif quand
on touche le fond c'est qu'on ne peut
pas aller plus bas alors durant ces deux
dernières années je suis passé par
énormément d'étapes j'ai dû changer
intérieurement pour pouvoir guérir
et ce changement je l'ai eu grâce à la
pensée positive
je ne vous parle pas d'un tour de magie
où il suffit de claquer les doigts pour
voir la vie en rose mais plutôt d'un
long processus qui se met en place petit
à petit un véritable mode de vie
alors pour moi ça s'est mis en place en
cas de grandes étapes la première a été
l'acceptation
l'acceptation de ma situation de ma
maladie et de tout ce qui va avec
ce déclic je l'ai pas eu du jour au
lendemain on me levant non je l'ai eu
après le quatrième changement de
médicaments c'est là que j'ai compris
que au final cette maladie allait me
suivre pour un bon bout de temps et que
au final je me fatiguais beaucoup plus à
lutter contre plutôt qu'à l'accepter
alors j'ai changé de penser et je l'ai
accueilli cette maladie et tout ce qui
va avec j'ai arrêté d'appréhender et
d'avoir peur des crises
l'acceptation c'est accepter tout ce qui
nous arrive que ça soit les épreuves les
émotions et autres
et en accueillant toutes ces choses et
ben on reprend le contrôle on reprend le
contrôle sur son corps mais aussi sur
ses pensées et on se laisse le choix de
notre réaction face à tout ce qui nous
arrive
et grâce à ça je suis passé de la
personne stressée pour tout et n'importe
quoi à quelqu'un de beaucoup plus posé
et qui est maître de ses émotions
ma deuxième étape a été de prendre
conscience des pensées négatives comme
je vous l'ai dit prendre conscience
c'est reprendre le contrôle et quand
vous prenez conscience de toutes ces
réflexions négatives que vous dites et
ben c'est beaucoup plus facile de les
contrer et les remplacer par des pensées
positives
également prendre conscience de ses
réflexions négatives c'est aussi prendre
conscience des facteurs déclencheurs que
ce soit un lieu ou bien des personnes
dans votre cercle privé ou bien
professionnel comme je vous l'ai dit moi
ça a été mon environnement de travail où
je côtoyais des personnes qui avaient
besoin de rabaisser constamment pour
voir se sentir existé et comme tout à
force d'entendre les mêmes choses tous
les jours et bien on finit par les
croire
et ça peut paraître bête ça peut
paraître simple de se dire il faut s'en
détacher il faut prendre du recul sauf
que moi ça m'a pris du temps ça m'a pris
énormément de temps pour pouvoir me
rendre compte que c'était ça tous ces
mots qu'on me répétait qui m'impactait
mais j'ai pu m'en libérer et avec du
temps j'ai pu transformer les je ne suis
pas capable je suis nul en je suis
capable et j'ai le potentiel pour
c'est ce qui m'amène à ma troisième
étape le conditionnement positif
le conditionnement positif pour moi
c'est pas d'être faussement optimiste en
se disant que tout va bien alors que
tout va mal mais plutôt un état d'esprit
qui nous pousse à trouver toujours un
point positif dans tout ce qui nous
arrive
de se dire que les échecs ce sont des
leçons que nous apprend la vie et que
les moments durs sont là pour nous
forger et nous façonner
comme je vous l'ai dit moi cette maladie
m'avait vraiment abattu
à tel point que je ne savais même plus
qui j'étais
pour la petite anecdote pour intégrer
mon Master j'ai dû passer par un
entretien d'admission cet entretien se
l'avait préparé pendant deux jours deux
jours parce qu'à ce moment là j'étais
incapable de me décrire ma personnalité
de donner mes qualités ou bien mes
défauts
ouais que ça mais ce changement de
pensée m'avait prendre conscience de
plein de choses premièrement que tout
était temporaire que cet état de crise
allait passer et qu'au final au bout du
tunnel il y a cette lumière
également pour moi la pensée c'est la
pierre de notre volonté que si on le
veut vraiment et bien on le peut
et donc j'ai aussi pris conscience que
tout était pas si noir autour de moi
et grâce à ça
j'ai pu guérir intérieurement
et être la personne que je suis devant
vous
et pour en arriver là j'ai dû passer à
l'action et c'est ma quatrième étape ce
passage à l'action on n'a pas besoin de
réaliser de très grands actions comme
marcher sur la lune non mais plutôt des
petits actes quotidiens réguliers et
avec lesquels on va façonner notre
réalité grâce à notre pensée pour moi ça
c'est matérialisé par la mise en place
d'une nouvelle routine pour pouvoir
vivre avec ma maladie
aujourd'hui les principaux déclencheurs
se sont les émotions intenses et
négatives comme des pics de colère ou
bien trop de stress vous inquiétez pas
je suis pas en crise
mais donc pour éviter tout le stress au
quotidien j'anticipe énormément
gentil je prépare toutes mes affaires la
veille et je me laisse toujours une
marge de 30 minutes à une heure donc
comme vous l'avez compris je suis plus
que ponctuel
j'ai commencé aussi à pratiquer une
activité physique régulière donc 4 à 5
fois par semaine je me lève à 5h et je
vais au sport avant d'aller travailler
et donc la mise en place de cette
nouvelle routine de cette discipline m'a
permis d'atteindre cet équilibre que je
cherchais tant mais aussi de me guérir
de me rendre beaucoup plus productive et
créative au quotidien et dans mon
travail
je me suis également éloigné de tout ce
qui était négatif pour moi que ça soit
des lieux ou bien des personnes dans mon
cercle privé et professionnel
aujourd'hui je vais m'entourer de
personnes qui sont bienveillantes dans
l'entourage sain et faire des choses que
j'aime et avec lesquelles je suis aligné
parce que pour moi dans ma déficience
dans ma définition de la réussite c'est
que comme ça qu'on peut réussir qu'en
faisant des choses qui nous passionnent
réellement
alors oui ces petites actions ne sont
pas de très grands actes mais pour moi
et mon permis d'avancer dans ma vie et
d'atteindre cet équilibre et grâce à
tout ça j'ai pu guérir intérieurement
comme je vous l'ai dit mais aussi mon
permis de découvrir mon pouvoir ma
pensée
qui me permet aujourd'hui d'être la
personne que vous avez devant vous et
cette personne aux multiples potentiel
et qui sait que sa seule limite et bien
si elle-même
un autre point important que j'aimerais
partager avec vous c'est d'être entouré
des bonnes personnes
à 20 ans je voulais absolument être
indépendantes bon maintenant avec du
recul je pense que c'était aussi la
crise de la vingtaine mais la vie m'a
mis une claque honnêtement et j'ai
compris que quatre entouré d'un
entourage sain de bonnes personnes et
bien c'était même pas une chance c'était
une bénédiction parce que quand on est
au plus bas ce sont ces personnes là qui
vont nous aider et qui vont nous tenir
la main quand on aura besoin
pour moi on est comme des petites fleurs
et on a besoin de ces graines nous
sommes les graines pardon et nous avons
besoin de soleil du vent de la pluie du
sol pour pouvoir nous épanouir et comme
elle on a besoin de cet entourage sain
pour toujours nous apporter quelque
chose
quand j'étais malade donc à 20 ans
j'avais le choix de continuer à sombrer
pendant plus de deux ans de toujours
sombrer de ma pitoyer sur mon sort en me
disant pourquoi moi qu'est-ce que j'ai
fait au destin pour mériter ça
ou bien un autre choix beaucoup plus
difficile qui prenait beaucoup plus de
temps et bien c'était de m'accrocher et
c'est celle que j'ai choisie alors je me
suis battu jour après jour pour pouvoir
revivre enfin normalement
et je suis content de vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui et ben je ne ressens plus
de boulot au ventre
et que je me sens bien
et j'espère qu'à travers mon histoire
vous avez pris conscience que vous avez
tous un pouvoir que nous avons tous un
pouvoir qui est la pensée parce que si
on le veut on le peut et grâce à la
pensée on peut tout créer on peut
façonner notre réalité
mais que tout comme tout travail tout
travail durable ce travail prend toute
une vie et demande de la rigueur
énormément de bienveillance mais surtout
envers vous-même
j'aimerais partager une citation avec
vous
qui dit que je ne peux pas changer la
direction du vent mais je peux toujours
ajuster mes voiles pour atteindre ma
destination
pour moi cette citation représente
exactement mon état d'esprit
qui fait que c'est vrai il y a plein de
choses sur lesquelles on n'a pas le
contrôle qui nous arriverons que ça soit
le deuil la maladie ou bien encore
d'autres épreuves mais nous on a le
pouvoir de pouvoir ajuster nos voiles
pour toujours atteindre notre
destination notre objectif et que malgré
tout ce qui nous arrivera nous avons le
pouvoir de rebondir et de tirer une
force dans chaque épreuve
et donc pour terminer j'aimerais vous
partager une dernière chose je sais je
dis beaucoup dernière mais bon
la prochaine fois que vous regarderez
dans un miroir que vous regarderez
réellement dans un miroir et pas juste
pour checker ce dernier bouton sur votre
visage j'aimerais que vous posiez ces
questions
êtes-vous fier de vous
et êtes-vous à votre plein potentiel
si la réponse est oui et bien sachez que
vous avez le pouvoir de dépasser vos
limites d'être encore meilleur que vous
êtes actuellement si vous le souhaitez
si la réponse est non
je pense vous avoir donné les clés pour
avoir un changement durable et un réel
impact dans vos vies
mais dans tous les cas c'est ce que je
vous souhaite et j'espère que vous
prendrez le pouvoir de le faire c'est
que vous avez le pouvoir d'exploser vos
performances alors faites-le merci
[Applaudissements]